[Musique]
rassemblez les enfants
la terre a été détruite par une grande guerre
j'ai été programmé pour vous protéger
et maintenant nous recommençons est-ce
que quelqu'un connait l'histoire des trois
petits cochons
le premier petit cochon a construit une maison
en paille
le second  petit cochon a rempli une maison avec des
bâtons
mais le troisième petit cochon il a construit une
maison en pierre
un jour
un grand méchant loup est arrivé et a dit
petit cochon rose laisse moi entrer ou je vais
souffler
et je vais souffler par eux et  je vais faire exploser ta
maison dans
un grand méchant loup elle parlait de
mère
c'est elle